Fruchtaufstrich und Erdbeer-Shake - bei
diesen Produkten kann ordentlich
getrickst werden. Wie viele frische Erdbeeren
da am Ende noch im Produkt landen und
was überhaupt als Marmelade verkauft
werden darf, zeigt euch Sebastian Lege.
In einen Erdbeer-Shake
kommen Erdbeeren, aber nicht so viele Erdbeeren
auch nicht so viele Erdbeeren, sondern so
viele Erdbeeren um so viel Shake zu machen.
Zeit zum Zaubern, wir fangen an zu
shaken. Wir nehmen das Wasser,
nehmen unsere Farbe von der Rote Bete,
Milchpulver. Bei so wenig Erdbeere
schmeckts natürlich noch nicht nach
Erdbeere, sondern jetzt schmeckts gleich
nach Erdbeere!
Möglichst preisgünstige Zutaten und
Chemie für den Geschmack.
Um das Ganze vollmundig-cremig zu machen
setzen wir Bindemittel ein.
Das Ganze machen wir jetzt auch noch
zuckersüß, ansonsten wird der
Erdbeer-Shake kein Erdbeer-Shake.
Und lassen langsam den Zucker reinrieseln.
Es sieht aus wie Erdbeere,
es riecht wie Erdbeere.
Es schmeckt nach Erdbeere, ist aber nur
so viel Erdbeere.
Nach diesem Prinzip kann
man gesunde, aber teure Zutaten sparen.
-Und wie sieht es bei Fruchtaufstrichen
aus? Wie wird hier an Erdbeeren gespart?
Tatsächlich sind Fruchtaufstriche wahre
Wundertüten.
Es gibt keine Vorgaben, woraus sie genau
bestehen müssen.
Dagegen ist besonders streng geregelt:
die "Konfitüre extra". Die muss mindestens
45% Frucht enthalten.
Außerdem liegt der Gesamtzuckergehalt wegen der
Haltbarkeit bei mindestens 55%.
Alles geregelt in der deutschen
Konfitüren-Verordnung. Bei der
Herstellung von Fruchtaufstrichen
dagegen, gibt es solche Vorschriften nicht.
Was alles möglich ist, wenn auf
einmal alles erlaubt ist, das zeigt
Produktentwickler Sebastian Lege.
Hier haben wir die kleine Mischmasch-Party
der Fruchtaufstriche. Da können wir reinhauen, was wir
wollen. Ob Johannisbeere, Fruchtsäfte,
in dem einem habe ich sogar eine Möhre gefunden. Da gibt es so Namen wie Crème Composé - ich meine ist
das schon ein Wort, wo man morgens auch schon
gleich ganz harmonisch wird oder?
Sebastian Lege macht einen Erdbeer-
Fruchtaufstrich mit nur wenig roten
Früchten.
Dafür umso mehr Karotten, Saftkonzentrat
und ganz viel aus dem Lebensmittellabor.
Ich würde mal sagen, simsalabim!
Bei seinem Fruchtaufstrich
ist einfach alles erlaubt, billige Möhren
zum Strecken und ein paar Johannisbeeren
für die Säure. Konfitüre darf sich das
nicht mehr nennen.
Das reicht aber jetzt auch an Erdbeeren,
weil wir haben noch Sirup, wir haben noch
Aroma, wir haben noch Saft.
Alles ordentlich vermixen und anschließend
mit etwas Sirup für den Geschmack und
Saft für die Farbe aufgießen - fertig ist
die Grundmasse.
Das sieht ja schon ganz
interessant aus, unser Beeren-Süppchen-
Erdbeer-Fruchtaufstrich. Riecht schon mal nicht so schlecht. Das Ganze jetzt durchs Sieb.
Einmal aufkochen lassen, etwas
konzentrierter Zitronensaft, ordentlich
süßen und damit die Suppe auch
irgendwann fest wird, eine mutige Dosis
vom Bindemittel Pektin. Und was ist mit
dem Karottengeschmack? Auch dagegen gibt es
das richtige Mittel.
Das gute Erdbeer-Aroma!
Mehr braucht man davon wirklich nicht.
Und das muss noch nicht einmal von der Erdbeere stammen.
Es kann auch aus Holzstoffen gewonnen werden und darf dennoch
natürliches Aroma heißen.
Und ab in den Kühlschrank.
Zwei Stunden später ist es soweit.
Sie ist kalt geworden, sieht doch ganz gut
aus. Fertig ist unsere Erdbeer-Poesie.
Einfach ein Fruchtaufstrich, wo alles drin
sein darf.
Da steht dem Sonntags-Frühstück ja
nichts mehr im Weg -  und wie schmeckt's?
Hmm! Also wer süß mag, aber dieses Erdbeeraroma ist schon echt krass.
Ein Erdbeer-Fruchtaufstrich mit wenig Erdbeeren, dafür aber mit vielen anderen Zutaten
aus der Trickkiste des Produktentwicklers.
Fruchtaufstriche sind also eine neue
Produktkategorie, die den Herstellern
viele Freiheiten ermöglichen. Wie sehr
machen die davon Gebrauch und gibt es
einen Unterschied zwischen No-Name und
Marke? Bei Zentis und Schwartau reicht
der Fruchtanteil von 45 bis zu 75%.
Die No-Names enthalten mindestens 50% Frucht
und sind deutlich billiger.
Am besten schneiden Aldi Süd und Nord,
sowie Lidl ab. 75% Erdbeeren für
je nur 99 Cent.
Aber Achtung: Fruchtaufstriche können
auch anders.
Speziell für Kinder setzt Zentis hier
auf günstigen Karottensaft und kommt auf
einen Fruchtanteil von nur noch 42%.
Ergebnis in unserer Stichprobe:
Bei No-Names gibt es mehr Frucht für
weniger Geld.
Habt ihr einen Fruchtaufstrich-Favoriten?
Oder macht ihr sie sogar selber? Sagt es
uns in den Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über eure
Lebensmittel wissen wollt, schaut in die
nächsten zwei Clips und abonniert die
ZDFbesseresser.